I make charm for Beyonce I make 10-piece
for her and I make a special charm for
today rocks every night I like to watch
a sub rocky music video because I like
to watch my merchandise my name is Eva
same my husband say your name is a sub
Eva at this point you may be wondering
who those is ASAP Eva and where does the
story going hell you might even be
asking yourself what is this story all
about fair enough let's start at the
beginning
Eva and her family emigrated to New York
from Macau in 1982 getting into the
jewelry business was a no-brainer for
Eva she comes from a long line of
jewelers we opened popular jewelry
in 1988 October in New York in the
beginning is difficult and then one day
the rap guard smiled down on her and
sent in Cappadonna wu-tang clan he's the
first rapper come to our store up to
that he sent all the people and we start
to have a lot of famous people come
[Music]
Travis Scott Jaden Smith Joey badass
calling young Paris
Wi-Fi funeral Macklemore famous people
come because we do everything on time
make a good job for them very quick and
have a fixed selection we have 24 karat
gold platinum diamond who
animals we have silver we have
everything and have a good personality I
don't treat them like a customer I took
them like my own kids it was a good day
[Music]
family and jewelry are synonymous to Eva
in fact the day after her son was born
she went straight back to work I will
not quit the job I'm here every single
day popular jewelry is more than the sum
of its glittery parts it's a family it's
a home and either is the my customer
call me goal model I have a lot and
lignum what they gave me
[Music]
India Kaiser Frankie khushboo Iran
duniya may such as data better manage
data the kappa come here apostasy silly
scholars wanna Baltic Aaron Amedeo
Madurai India Kashmir see who America a
saffron casbah remember secretive
Arikara many a blip
mandhaakini variably boxes he
immediately soccer proper time it's a
funky full duty in seiza practical time
yet among treason [ __ ] among policy a
logic fully we are politically you
attain the optimum to super Bihar ITF
multiple may whisper karate kata Sujata
group to Burma barrage a spirit
he'll also nicely voltage Akari vitamin
a villain Darko subsequent about Johanna
Tina's arpita's grand each a
other IQ loser Frankie D Sookie's a
Frankie D which is given food is over
paddy a monoplane a taste of America
spearmint outlaw and district Miata
quiero comprar malate or share a cynical
de sucre co-team ratio Desmond a poor
man
harakiri Shruti Rajab is October Pashto
Jota to whom bikini car car keys area
panel EKG full today
Diamond Sutra temple l-jamaa car key
busy day the Transit Authority Quixote a
yo mama sodomy garam masala - TK make a
parameter value Makati an attack enemy
today of furoshiki limited a kimochi
over agenda Srinivasa t miss radensky
Mara sarah diarmuid easy para or the
road behave Mukhopadhyay risky
[Music]
in an Alpine Valley in western
Switzerland lies a city at the very
heart of an area known as watch Valley
this is LA chaux-de-fonds
this is one of the beating hearts of the
Swiss watchmaking industry welcome to
the city of time Yallah Yallah shot for
nanu Avenue
[Music]
- okay de mantenimiento NASA dollar
scholarship from Tonka start on Hawaii
Calexico the zoo geology - Luke this is
for more dollars to look at the times a
year satella capital issues Jocassee a
new prison at attraction a pier optional
entire planet Abajo
so function more if I want to email a
mechanic
Kapila delicate s Loukas is your natural
real zoology you can the long hose
manufacturer's warranty see if you leave
her like a giant otter myopathy Queen
usually occurs in are the young player
jpg or Venetian study a short form
decision second system to declare so 22
in the Vinland written as surely
the only cat the principal manufacturer
Oliver Jaya he Jaya clear should fall in
with example talk it turns of Hawaii
population limits appeared to help you
model a few thousand e da scam or
external objects locally Neiman Pahlavi
don't care GRI grocery commercials onto
the set Mandela the polish is kept
hidden under the different the diamond
remember to set fee nineteen video Elmo
allow for a design a to fake you see so
also unique it is expected kanou
precision return Dimitri's do Tony
calculate on water Otto's wanna Julie
Avalon servos akadama magazine evil
average al-assad for trade owned
Amendola read appeared on a previous
recollection of the moon the pivot angle
Maison de la vie de la república de
semana para strands decay he deeply
schizophrenic
dr. Chris Taub Zelda Gallatin Joshua
[Music]
oops decision really exam de mundo push
automatic attraction II said mode
working as of anomie pure solution i
want to reserve affair do not pursue
relations Deborah t2 / kappa a
precondition a pioneer in origins of
logic more compared to the needle
already pediment a regal more assign a
potential capital parabola shot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Safran beluga caviar truffles and bana
potatoes are just some of the world's
most expensive foods weight potatoes is
that right
guys it says here on the script potatoes
potato seriously
welcome to nor monte air at i li island
of the atlantic coast of france
this is the only place you can find the
king of potatoes his majesty love bomb
mount but if you want to eat them fresh
you've got to be quick as they're only
available for 10 days a year this is
Rudy he's a potato farmer so what makes
the island of nwandi air so special for
these spuds
sedessa mousse to feed us for premium
[Music]
oh sweet little girl is a porter a
glutton not at all I'm only something
more that they are incalculable new
definition all the farmers on the island
are part of cooperative they do with
treating cleaning selling and sending
all over Europe
[Music]
Nicholas is the director he makes sure
everything runs smoothly he really loves
these potatoes Odie Odie de l'épée me
Bernardo et voila sorry
hello le fragile NEPA mechanism sipoc
Saco do sombrio de l'homme Salama like
all the labor not Sophia newsmen dill
evolved surf a unique Monsieur du jour
now I hope you're sitting down because
in 1996 these pricey potatoes fetch the
auction and insane amount drumroll
roughly $500 per pound luckily for you
and me nowadays bonnet potatoes aren't
gonna break the bank
fetching more like $5 per pound which is
still a lot for a bag of potatoes sail
upon the television or
see a unison total na zdravi artisanal
they don't deposit associate unfair
since key officer other analog world
Alfonso to table table a pass to Apollo
you
we will assist you Donna peeling it off
it's only one table
[Music]
once the harvest is complete an annual
bonnet festival is held here the golden
potatoes are traditionally served with
grilled sardines so holiday taste see
top 100 in pommes de terre have a
co-anchor ossifer from the Terre des
hommes you were in several shaping
America's most paper mache Ruggiano
discs in Napa Hankou dzasta haunt me on
a film of the dual comp Lizzie her
daughter akiza Nate so there we have it
the king of potatoes thank you your
majesty
[Music]